nous savons que, jusqu'à son éradication,
la polio reste une menace réelle,
spécialement pour les enfants dans les communautés les plus pauvres au monde.
Elle peut réapparaître dans certains endroits les plus éloignés et dangereux,
et se répandre à partir de là.
Je vous présente mon nouveau Ironman :
mettre fin à la polio.
Je me le rappelle tous les jours,
en regardant ma fille de deux ans et demi, Maya.
Elle est capable de grimper les échelles au parc,
de pousser sa trottinette ou taper dans un ballon.
Pratiquement tout ce que je l'observe faire à son âge
me rappelle tout ce que je ne pouvais pas faire à son âge.
À l'âge de deux mois,
je l'ai emmenée faire son premier vaccin contre la polio.
Lorsque le docteur est venu dans la pièce pour préparer la piqûre,
je lui ai demandé si je pouvais prendre une photo pour documenter ce moment.
Lorsque nous avons quitté la pièce,
je pouvais sentir mes yeux se remplir de larmes.
J'ai pleuré tout au long du retour.
C'est à ce moment-là que j'ai réalisé
que la vie de ma fille serait très différente de la mienne.
Elle ne sera jamais confrontée avec le handicap paralysant de la polio,
parce qu'un vaccin était disponible, et que j'ai choisi de la faire vacciner.
Elle peut faire tout ce qu'elle veut,
comme chacun de vous.
(Rires)
J'aimerais vous quitter avec une question :
quel est votre Ironman ?
Merci.
(Applaudissements)